Here's the story the way we usually like it. There's this guy. And he's behind enemy lines. Maybe he's dropped in there in the middle of the night. Maybe he sneaks under barbwire at the border. Whatever. He's there. He's been there awhile. Months. Years maybe. He's in disguise. Working on our behalf. Nobody suspects. No one can tell. He looks and acts just like them. And then, living there in their midst for so long, speaking their language, eating their food, breathing their air, watching their TV shows, something happens. He starts to change. He starts to become more like them. And then when it's time for him to strike, to launch his mission against them, he hesitates. He's not sure who he sympathizes with anymore.
这就是我们通常喜欢的故事。有一个人，他深入敌后。也许他是半夜空降进去的。也许他是从边境的铁丝网下潜入的。不管怎样，他就在那里。他已经在那里待了一段时间。几个月，甚至几年。他乔装打扮，为我们效力。没有人怀疑，没人能看出来。他的外貌和举止与他们完全一样。然后，在他们中间生活了这么久，说着他们的语言，吃着他们的食物，呼吸着他们的空气，看着他们的电视节目，事情发生了变化。他开始改变，他开始变得越来越像他们。然后，当他该发起进攻、执行针对他们的任务时，他犹豫了。他不确定自己现在到底同情哪一方。
It's a very romantic idea, this particular vision of what it means to live inside the enemy camp. And you lose your bearings and you will forget how to fight because some other impulse inside you would take over. But sometimes, this is actually how it happens. There are lots of ways that people get confused about who their enemy is and how to fight them.
这是一种非常浪漫的想法，这种关于潜伏在敌营意味着什么的独特愿景。你会迷失方向，你会忘记如何战斗，因为你内心深处的某种冲动会占据主导地位。但有时，现实确实就是这样发生的。人们对于谁是敌人以及如何与他们战斗，会产生各种各样的困惑。
Today on our radio show we have that story, happening to several different people, in several different places, in several different ways. True stories.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们将讲述这个故事，它发生在几个不同的人身上，在几个不同的地方，以几种不同的方式。这是真实的故事。
WBEZ, Chicago. This is American Life. distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose some subject. Bring you documentaries, interviews, short fiction, found tapes, found writing. Anything we can think of on that subject. Today on our program, life behind enemy lines. Our program today in four acts. Act One: Confession. In that Act, the true story of a fixer for the Catholic Church. And now he came to sympathize with people who he was sent by the church to deceive. Act Two: Blood Agent. How microscopic beings inside you and me can control our thoughts and minds. No kidding. Act Three: As The Worm Turns. The story of a man who invites the enemy inside. And I mean really inside. Act Four: Sleeping With The Enemy, in which we ask who's side is your girlfriend on anyway.
WBEZ，芝加哥。《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。每周在我们的节目中，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来纪录片、采访、短篇小说、搜集的录音带、搜集的文字，任何我们能想到的关于那个主题的内容。今天节目的主题是：敌后生活。我们今天的节目分为四个篇章。第一幕：忏悔。在这一幕中，讲述了一个天主教会“清理人”的真实故事。以及他是如何开始同情那些教会派他去欺骗的人们的。第二幕：血液代理人。讲述我们体内微小的生物是如何控制我们的思想和精神的。别开玩笑了，这是真的。第三幕：当虫子蠕动时。讲述一个引狼入室的男人的故事。我是说，真正的“入室”。第四幕：与敌同眠，在这一幕中，我们要问：你的女朋友到底站在哪一边？
Act One: Confession. It's Easter week. Pope Benedict has been facing a lot of criticism with allegations that he didn't adequately discipline priests who were accused of sexual abuse, back before Pope Benedict was a Pope, back when he was an Archbishop and a Cardinal. So we've decided to revisit a story that we first broadcast in 2003, about a young American priest who was sent out on a series of jobs by church administrators to squelch some scandals. Scandals not too different from the ones that are surfacing in the news right now. But spending time out among the people who he's supposed to be deceiving, the priest finds it harder and harder to keep doing his job. Carl Marziali tells the story from Los Angeles.
第一幕：忏悔。现在是复活节周。教皇本笃十六世一直面临着许多批评，指责他在担任教皇之前，即担任大主教和枢机主教期间，没有对被指控性虐待的牧师进行充分的纪律处分。因此，我们决定重温一个我们在2003年首次播出的故事，讲述的是一位年轻的美国牧师被教会行政人员派去执行一系列任务，以压制一些丑闻。这些丑闻与现在新闻中浮出的丑闻没什么两样。但是，在与他本应欺骗的人群中相处了一段时间后，这位牧师发现自己越来越难继续他的工作了。卡尔·马齐亚利（Carl Marziali）从洛杉矶讲述这个故事。
Patrick Wall was just where he wanted to be at 26. He was a monk, studying theology at St. John's Monastery in rural Minnesota. He lived in a quiet room facing the lake. He looked forward to a life of study and prayer. It was late summer, 1991.
帕特里克·沃尔（Patrick Wall）在26岁时正处于他梦想中的地方。他是一名僧侣，在明尼苏达州乡村的圣约翰修道院学习神学。他住在一个面朝湖泊的安静房间里，期待着过一种学习和祈祷的生活。那是1991年的夏末。
The first day that school started out, pretty uneventful, winter morning prayer at 7:00 o'clock like normal. I went down for breakfast like normal. Went back up to my room. Was literally brushing my teeth when there was a knock on my door, which is extremely out of the ordinary. And it was Abbot Jerome Tyson. Well, the abbot's a very quiet guy. And he usually never went up on that floor of the monastery. So he says, "May I come in?" I said, "Yes, Father Abbot. No problem." So he comes in and sits down. And I've got my books out. I've got class in 10 minutes. "What's up?" And he said, "Well, Father Dan Ward has told me that you would be a good person for this particular job. And we have a situation over in St. Mary's Hall that we need to be a faculty resident."
开学的第一天，很平静，早上7点照常做晨祷。我像往常一样去吃早餐，回到房间。正刷着牙时，有人敲我的门，这非常不寻常。那是院长杰罗姆·泰森（Abbot Jerome Tyson）。院长是一个非常安静的人，他通常从不去修道院的那一层。他说：“我可以进来吗？”我说：“当然可以，院长神父。没问题。”他走进来坐下。我当时把书拿出来了，再过10分钟就要上课了。“怎么了？”他说：“丹·沃德（Dan Ward）神父告诉我，你是这份特定工作的合适人选。我们需要在圣玛丽大厅安排一名教职员工入驻。”
The faculty resident is a live-in counselor at the college dorm. The campus at St. John's includes a university.
教职员工入驻是指担任大学宿舍的住校辅导员。圣约翰学院的校园里包含一所大学。
I said, "Well, I'd love to be a faculty resident someday. I think that's a great idea." And he said, "No, today." And when I asked Abbot Jerome specifically what it was for, what was going on, he said, "Well, I can't tell you that." We had numerous sexual abuse cases that had been popping up. So ultimately there's only one conclusion that can be drawn that there was an allegation that they must have thought somewhat credible or probable. And they needed to pull that particular monk. And off I went.
我说：“我以后很想成为住校辅导员，我觉得这是个好主意。”他说：“不，是今天。”当我问杰罗姆院长具体是为了什么，发生了什么事时，他说：“好吧，我不能告诉你。”我们当时确实出现过很多性虐待案件。所以最终只能得出一个结论，那就是有一项指控，他们一定认为多少有些可信或可能。他们需要调走那个特定的僧侣。然后我就出发了。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL'S ULULU" BY  DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
That afternoon, Wall moved his stuff out of his room and into the freshman dorm. His instructions were simple. Put the kids at ease. And don't say anything about the monk you're replacing. He organized a pizza party for the students. He told them he was taking over as faculty resident, but that he couldn't say why. There were no questions. Wall didn't know it then, but he was being tested. Unfortunately for him, he passed. His dream was to be a monk as he understood monks to be. Devout and learned men who live in monasteries. By showing a knack for damage control, he put himself on a less spiritual path.
那天下午，沃尔把他的东西搬出了房间，住进了新生宿舍。他的指令很简单：让孩子们放松，不要提你接替的那个僧侣。他为学生们组织了一个披萨派对。他告诉他们，他接手担任住校辅导员，但不能说原因。学生们没问什么。沃尔当时不知道，他正在接受考验。不幸的是，他通过了。他的梦想是成为他所理解的那种僧侣：虔诚、博学，住在修道院里的男人。通过展现出处理危机的天分，他走上了一条不那么属灵的道路。
Before long, the abbot appointed him to a sexual abuse response team. And sent him to the church of St. Elizabeth's in the town of Hastings. He was replacing a pastor who had been withdrawn for what the monastery called a incredible allocation. Wall arrived at St. Elizabeth's on February 2, 1993.
没过多久，院长任命他加入一个性虐待应对小组，并派他去黑斯廷斯镇的圣伊丽莎白教堂。他要接替一位牧师，那位牧师因所谓的“不可思议的指控”而被撤职。沃尔于1993年2月2日抵达圣伊丽莎白教堂。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL'S ULULU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
Replacing a pastor is not easy. People in a parish tend to get attached to the priest. Replacing a disgraced pastor is harder. A lot of people believe their priest can do no wrong. And they are not shy about telling his replacement.
接替一位牧师并不容易。教区的居民往往会对牧师产生依恋。接替一位名誉扫地的牧师更难。许多人相信他们的牧师不会做错事，他们丝毫不介意告诉他的继任者。
They were very forward and forthright and angry. And they said, "Father, I'm really sad that you're here. I'm really sorry that you had to come because we really liked the other monk. And we don't think he should have been removed." And that was it. And I said, "I'm really sorry that that particular monk had to be removed. And I'm here because my abbot asked me to be here." I'm tried to be as candid and simple as possible. But I felt taken back. And I felt sad from the very beginning. And I didn't enjoy that experience.
他们非常直接、坦率且愤怒。他们说：“神父，你在这里让我很难过。我真的很遗憾你不得不来，因为我们真的很喜欢原来的那位僧侣。我们认为他不应该被撤职。”就是这样。我说：“我很遗憾那位僧侣不得不被撤职。我是因为院长的要求才在这里的。”我尽量表现得坦诚和简单。但我感到很受挫。从一开始我就感到很难过，我并不享受那种经历。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL'S ULULU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
At first, Wall was trying to raise morale. He told parishioners what he himself had been told. That the alleged abuse took place a, some time ago. And b, somewhere else. But it wasn't long before victims at St. Elizabeth's began coming forward. They would show up unannounced at the rectory or in the church after mass and ask to speak to him in private. Then they would start with a tiny revelation.
起初，沃尔试图提高士气。他告诉教区居民他自己被告知的情况：即所谓的虐待发生在一、很久以前；二、在别的地方。但没过多久，圣伊丽莎白教堂的受害者们就开始站出来。他们会在弥撒结束后不请自来地出现在牧师住宅或教堂里，要求私下和他谈话。然后他们会从一个微小的披露开始。
It's unforgettable. It's absolutely unforgettable when they start to tell you. And they only tell you very small, cryptic little things. There are code words for everything. And they've kind of broached the subject to see what you're going to do with it. And to see if you're going to actually believe them. Obviously I'm 27 years old. I'm not exactly sure what to do with it. Emotionally, I really have no idea what to do it.
这令人难忘。当他们开始告诉你时，绝对令人难忘。他们只会告诉你一些非常细小、晦涩的事情。一切都有代号。他们以这种方式试探你，看你要怎么处理，看你是否真的会相信他们。显然我当时才27岁。我确实不知道该怎么处理。在情感上，我真的完全不知道该怎么办。
So how did you deal with it when the victim or victims came forward and told you about what had happened? Do you try to comfort them? Do you try to tell them that-- I mean, what do you do? Do you try to restore their faith in the church? Or do you just listen and write up a complaint and send it on?
那么，当受害者站出来告诉你发生了什么事时，你是怎么处理的？你会试着安慰他们吗？你会试着告诉他们——我的意思是，你会做什么？你会试着恢复他们对教会的信仰吗？还是你只是倾听，写下投诉并发送出去？
You don't even write up a complaint basically. You get a few of the facts. And then you pass that on to the diocese. And honestly, unfortunately it's easy to deal with because these people never go to church again. Because they really view that person as representing God. So it's hard for them to publicly ever celebrate or to practice their faith again. So they just disappear honestly.
你基本上甚至不用写投诉。你获取一些事实，然后将其传递给教区。老实说，不幸的是，这很容易处理，因为这些人再也不会去教堂了。因为他们真的把那个人看作是上帝的代表。所以他们很难再公开庆祝或实践他们的信仰。老实说，他们就这样消失了。
Did you ever wonder whether you should make a special effort when they came to you beyond the effort that you might make to convince somebody else to come back to the church? To do something more for these victims. Or to offer them counseling or something to try to make up for what had happened?
你有没有想过，当他们来找你时，你应该比说服别人回教会付出更多努力吗？为这些受害者多做点什么，或者为他们提供咨询，或者做些什么来弥补所发生的一切？
It's a difficult situation because you really need to remain neutral. And your natural inclination, especially as priests, is to be sympathetic and to heal. But there's no way that you're going to be allowed to be part of the healing process because ultimately you're part of the defendant. You are the institution that brought about the hurt. And so you really have to put your professional hat on and keep an arm's distance.
这是一个困难的情况，因为你需要保持中立。而且你的自然倾向，特别是作为牧师，是去同情和治愈。但你根本不可能被允许参与治愈过程，因为归根结底你是被告的一部分。你就是造成伤害的机构。所以你真的必须戴上专业的帽子，保持距离。
Wall survived the scandal at St. Elizabeth's. And he helped a superior survive it too. He never told parishioners about the allegations in their parish. And the stories he was hearing in private never became problem.
沃尔在圣伊丽莎白教堂的丑闻中幸存了下来。他还帮助一位上级也幸存了下来。他从未告诉教区居民关于他们教区内的指控。他在私下里听到的故事也从未成为问题。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL'S ULULU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
After serving a year at St. Elizabeth's, Wall thought he would come back to the monastery. But the end of this term he received a letter from the abbot, instructing him to report to another parish, St. Bernard's. The monk there have been having an affair and paying for it with church money. This was not the assignment Wall had in mind, but part of him was flattered.
在圣伊丽莎白教堂工作了一年后，沃尔以为他会回到修道院。但任期结束时，他收到了院长的一封信，指示他前往另一个教区，圣伯纳德教堂。那里的僧侣一直在搞婚外情，并用教会的钱买单。这不是沃尔心目中的任务，但他的一部分感到受宠若惊。
I felt pretty good about it because all of a sudden-- I'm 20 years old and I'm an administrator of a parish. I'm being turned loose as the boss. That's a compliment as far as I'm concerned. And I really felt I was doing the right thing.
我当时感觉还不错，因为突然间——我20多岁（注：原文此处应为口误，后文提到他33岁离开，此处应指20多岁末期），我就成了一个教区的管理者。我被放出来作为老板。就我而言，这是一种恭维。我真的觉得我在做正确的事。
Not long after Wall arrived at St. Bernard's, an agent from the IRS knocked on his door. The agent presented a bill, payable immediately, for $600,000 in back taxes, interest, and penalties for undeclared profits from a church run lottery. The business manager was not available to answer questions because he had been the other person in the affair. And had been removed along with the monk. Wall had to take a crash course in bookkeeping to pay the IRS.
沃尔到达圣伯纳德教堂后不久，一名国税局（IRS）探员敲了他的门。探员出示了一张必须立即支付的账单，金额为60万美元的补缴税款、利息和罚款，原因是教会经营的彩票未申报利润。业务经理无法回答问题，因为他就是那场婚外情的另一方，并且已经和那位僧侣一起被撤职了。沃尔不得不参加了速成的簿记课程来偿还国税局。
The rest of his time at St. Bernard's, Wall did what every priest does. He celebrated mass, performed weddings and funerals, baptized babies. And he heard confessions, including those of other priests.
在圣伯纳德教堂剩下的时间里，沃尔做了每个牧师都会做的事：主持弥撒，举行婚礼和葬礼，为婴儿施洗。他还倾听忏悔，包括其他牧师的忏悔。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL'S ULULU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
Despite the headlines, the percentage of priests who have abused minors is relatively low. Celibacy is another story. In a recent Los Angeles Times poll, only one third of priests said they do not waiver from a celibate life. After awhile, Wall stopped thinking of broken vows as something foreign to his world.
尽管有头条新闻，但虐待未成年人的牧师比例相对较低。独身主义是另一回事。在最近《洛杉矶时报》的一项民意调查中，只有三分之一的牧师表示他们没有违背独身生活。一段时间后，沃尔不再认为违背誓言是他世界之外的事。
You know, once you seen enough people fall and once you hear enough confessions of different priests, you look at yourself in the mirror and you say, "Am I really any different?" And the chances of me maintaining a celibate way of life without failure along the way are so low that ultimately either I have to change or the system needs to change.
你知道，一旦你看到足够多的人堕落，听到足够多牧师的忏悔，你就会照镜子对自己说：“我真的有什么不同吗？”而我维持独身生活而不中途失败的可能性太低了，最终要么是我必须改变，要么是制度必须改变。
What about-- there must be a lot of priests who believe in being priests. And have decided that the rule of celibacy is nonsense. And so are willing to lead a double life of sorts. Was that-- that wasn't something that you considered?
那么——一定有很多牧师相信成为牧师的意义。并且决定独身规则是胡说八道。所以愿意过一种双重生活。那是——那不是你考虑过的事情吗？
No, that's really not my personality. I'm a terrible liar. Oh. I turn red. I'm really bad. And I had seen priests who maintained heterosexual relationships with women. And I saw the effects of it. Because it's a life of contradiction. Because the relationship is there. It's exclusive. But you can't profess it. And everyone around you knows it's going on. And that's not happiness. That's not a true coming together. I just couldn't see myself doing that. That's just not me.
不，那真的不是我的性格。我是一个糟糕的骗子。哦，我会脸红。我真的很差劲。我见过维持与女性异性恋关系的牧师。我看到了后果。因为那是一种矛盾的生活。因为关系存在，它是排他的。但你不能公开它。周围的每个人都知道发生了什么。那不是幸福，那不是真正的结合。我只是无法想象自己那样做。那真的不是我。
After St. Bernard's, the assignments kept coming. The next one was an affair between a priest and a nun. After that, a new parish where a teacher had abused a student and the priest was living with his housekeeper. Four years. Four parishes. Four scandals. There are good, dedicated priests out there. But they're not the ones who get replaced. By the very nature of his job, Wall was acquiring a skewed and depressing view of the priesthood.
在圣伯纳德之后，任务接踵而至。下一个任务是关于一位牧师和一位修女之间的恋情。在那之后，是一个新的教区，那里的一名教师虐待了一名学生，而牧师正和他的管家住在一起。四年。四个教区。四起丑闻。外面有优秀的、敬业的牧师，但他们不是被调换的那些人。通过他工作的本质，沃尔正在获得一种扭曲且令人沮丧的牧师观点。
Did you ever ask not to be given those assignments?
你有没有要求过不要被分配这些任务？
Yeah. I did. And I specifically asked to be able to come back to the prep school and teach. But the needs of the monastery were so great at that point that again, it was only going to be another year. I was only going to have to go to St. Bernard's for another year. So it sounds like a bad construction deal. Two more weeks. Give me two more weeks and we'll be done. And it just kept going on. And it kept going on.
有。我要求过。而且我明确要求能回到预科学校教书。但当时修道院的需求太大了，所以同样，那只是最后一年。我只需要再去圣伯纳德教堂一年。这听起来像是一个糟糕的建筑合同：再给我两周，再给我两周我们就完成了。它就这样一直持续下去，持续下去。
Meanwhile, the monks he replaced were getting exactly what Wall himself had asked for. They were going back to the monastary, permanently.
与此同时，他接替的那些僧侣却得到了沃尔自己所要求的东西。他们永久地回到了修道院。
I'd run across them at community meetings. And whenever we had chapter votes, and all that. And it's hard not to be judgmental.
我在社区会议上遇到他们，每当我们进行章节投票等等时。很难不带偏见。
The other thing I found hard was that my whole career path was driven by other people's mistakes. And that's the last thing I ever expected in monastic life. I really expected to work in a parish for a year, to go off to grad school, come back, teach, coach football at the university. And to live a pretty darn good life-- a balance between prayer and teaching and working as a teacher. So-- They changed my career path. They changed my whole trajectory in life.
我发现另一件困难的事情是，我的整个职业道路都是由别人的错误驱动的。这是我在修道院生活中最没想到的。我真的期望在教区工作一年，去读研究生，回来，教书，在大学教橄榄球。过一种相当不错的生活——一种在祈祷、教书和作为教师工作之间的平衡。所以——他们改变了我的职业道路，他们改变了我整个人生的轨迹。
Without fully realizing it, Wall have been initiated into a brotherhood of priests known informally as fixers or cleaners. They replaced problem priests. They hide things in the archives. They reassure the faithful. In short, they make it all go away.
在没有完全意识到的情况下，沃尔被引入了一个非正式地被称为“清理人”或“清理者”的牧师兄弟会。他们接替有问题的牧师，把事情藏在档案里，安抚信众。简而言之，他们让一切消失。
Visually, he was perfect for the job. He's was barrel-chested, a former offensive lineman on the St. John's football team. He was young and friendly. He was the anti-stereotype of a troubled monk. The abbot couldn't have found a better prospect if he had picked a model out of a catalogue. But Wall did more than just PR. He became familiar with the law of the church called cannon law. Specifically, with the different archives cannon law sets up for storing and hiding information.
从视觉上讲，他是这份工作的完美人选。他胸部宽阔，是圣约翰橄榄球队的前进攻锋。他年轻且友好。他是麻烦僧侣的反面教材。院长如果从目录里挑出一个模特，也不可能找到比他更好的候选人了。但沃尔做的不仅仅是公关。他变得熟悉教会法，特别是教会法为存储和隐藏信息而设立的各种档案。
The first is the historical archives, which is just the names, states, people, those kinds of things. Then you have the secret archives.
第一种是历史档案，那只是名字、状态、人物，诸如此类的东西。然后你有秘密档案。
The secret archives-- is that literally what they're called-- the secret archives? I mean, why were they set up?
秘密档案——那是它们的字面名称吗，秘密档案？我的意思是，它们为什么要设立？
They're set up for the protection of individuals. So the bishop has the responsibility to take things that would be considered scandalous, things that might hurt individuals' reputations, and to be able place them there so they wouldn't easily be exposed.
它们是为了保护个人而设立的。所以主教有责任把那些被认为是丑闻的、可能伤害个人名誉的事情，放置在那里，这样它们就不会轻易暴露。
OK When you call it the secret archives though, it makes it sound sinister. It makes it sound like it's there for the protection-- to really protect the church. I'm not saying that's what it is. But that's how it sounds. I mean what really is the purpose of these so-called secrets? Why can't everything be in the personnel records. And then some items just be labelled confidential or whatever?
好的。但当你称它为秘密档案时，它听起来很阴险。它听起来好像是为了保护——真正是为了保护教会。我不是说那是什么，但听起来就是这样。我的意思是，这些所谓的秘密的真正目的是什么？为什么不能把所有东西都放在人事记录里？然后有些项目只是被标记为机密或类似的？
Well, you've got to give Rome credit. I mean they have wonderful procedure. This is things that have worked out for centuries. And that has always been the secret to one of the defenses of the church. If you don't know what you're asking for, they don't have to produce it.
嗯，你必须得给罗马记上一功。我的意思是，他们有很棒的程序。这是几个世纪以来一直行之有效的事情。这一直是教会防御的秘密之一。如果你不知道你在要求什么，他们就不必提供它。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL'S ULULU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
Did you ever-- when you were working for the church, cleaning up these situations of abuse and having to tell parishioners some of the facts, but not all of the facts about what was going on, did you ever feel complicit in the cover-up of all of this?
你有没有——当你在为教会工作，清理这些虐待情况，不得不告诉教区居民部分事实，但不是关于正在发生的所有事实时，你有没有感到在所有这些掩盖行为中是共犯？
I have some regrets. But I think I did it in good faith. Because as I was taught and as I believed, that was my role, to help the church in the long run. And to be obedient to what I was asked to do. And it's only later on as I had greater experience that I couldn't support it any longer. And I felt that if I was going to stay, I was going to not only support it but I was going to get deeper into it.
我有过一些遗憾。但我认为我是在善意的情况下做的。因为正如我所受教的和我相信的那样，那是我的角色，从长远来看帮助教会。并服从我被要求做的事情。只是后来随着我有了更多的经验，我再也无法支持它了。我觉得如果我要留下来，我不仅会支持它，我还会陷入得更深。
I was going to be asked to do other assignments to follow pedophiles. I was going to be asked to be on the finance council to try to figure out ways to mitigate the huge financial costs of childhood sexual abuse by priests and the religious. And I remember having an epiphany. And sitting on the porch at St. Mary's in Stillwater. And that's when I came to the conclusion that this is pretty much going to be my career path. I'd be there for another year or two as the administrator. And then I would go on to another assignment. And I just couldn't do it any longer.
我会被要求执行其他任务去跟踪恋童癖者。我会被要求进入财务委员会，试图想出办法来减轻神职人员和宗教人员对儿童进行性虐待所带来的巨大财务成本。我记得有过一次顿悟。当时坐在圣玛丽大厅的门廊上。那时候我得出的结论是，这基本就是我的职业道路了。我会作为行政人员在那里待上一两年。然后我会去接受另一个任务。我再也做不下去了。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL'S ULULU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
After four years of deceiving the faithful about the extent of priests and misconduct, of protecting the institution over the health and welfare of the victims, of covering for the perpetrators and letting the problem fester, Patrick Wall decided he was on the wrong side. On July 31, 1998, Wall quit the priesthood. He was 33 years old.
在四年的时间里，欺骗信众关于牧师的不当行为程度，为了机构的利益而牺牲受害者的健康和福利，为加害者掩盖并让问题恶化，帕特里克·沃尔决定他站错了队。1998年7月31日，沃尔退出了牧师职位。他当时33岁。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL'S ULULU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
Leaving was difficult. If you want to leave honorably, you need permission, which doesn't come easily or quickly. It took more than a year in Wall's case. Then once you're out, there are practical challenges, like trying to get a job with a Master of Theology on your resume. In the end, it was his experience as a fixer that translated best to the real world. Wall read an op-ed in the LA Times, by John Manley, an attorney who sues the church on behalf of sexual abuse victims.
离开很困难。如果你想体面地离开，你需要许可，这不容易也不快。沃尔的情况花了一年多时间。然后一旦你出来，就有实际的挑战，比如试图在你的简历上带着神学硕士学位找工作。最后，是他作为清理人的经验最能转化到现实世界。沃尔读了《洛杉矶时报》上一篇专栏文章，作者是约翰·曼利（John Manley），一位代表性虐待受害者起诉教会的律师。
He essentially separated himself amongst all the different attorneys in saying that we need to protect the sheep and not the shepherd. It's not the problem of the victims. It's not the problem of the particular perpetrators, per se, or some particular issue like homosexuality, or whatever. The problem is within the institution itself.
他从本质上将自己与所有其他律师区分开来，说我们需要保护羊群，而不是牧羊人。这不是受害者的问题，本身也不是特定加害者的问题，或者同性恋之类的特定问题。问题在于机构本身。
By this point, Wall was convinced that lawsuits where the only way to reform the church. He called Manley and offered to help. Soon they were on the phone constantly. Wall took him step by step through church bureaucracy. Manley was amazed.
到这一点，沃尔确信诉讼是改革教会的唯一途径。他给曼利打了电话，提出帮忙。很快他们就一直在电话沟通。沃尔一步步带他了解教会官僚机构。曼利感到很惊讶。
John didn't know all the different documents that are out there. And then John will be working on things and he'd call me up, and said, "Dude, what do I do with this? What does this mean? What am I supposed to do with it? What are other things can I-- where else can I look?" And I remember-- I think he was quite surprised when I showed him the penal code of canon law and exactly what we need to ask for. He just couldn't believe that it was there. That they would have that level of sophistication.
约翰不知道那里有所有那些不同的文件。然后约翰会处理事情，他会打电话给我说：“老兄，我该怎么处理这个？这是什么意思？我该怎么处理它？我还能在哪里看？”我记得——我想当他看到教会法刑法典以及我们需要准确要求什么时，他非常惊讶。他简直不敢相信它就在那里。他们竟然有那种程度的复杂性。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL'S ULULU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
Wall started working for Manley's law firm full-time in October of 2002. Using his knowledge of Latin and Italian, he translates and interprets church records. He helps the firm identify and request key documents, like psychological assessment of priests, from the secret archives. The fact that he switched sides, that's he's fighting the church, doesn't seem to trouble him. He believes he is doing what God wants them to do, which is what he's always believed.
沃尔于2002年10月开始全职为曼利的律师事务所工作。利用他懂拉丁语和意大利语的知识，他翻译和解读教会记录。他帮助律所识别并索取关键文件，比如从秘密档案中获取牧师的心理评估报告。他切换了立场、正在与教会对抗的事实，似乎并没有困扰他。他相信他在做上帝希望他们做的事，这正是他一直以来所相信的。
[MUSIC - ANGEL'S ULULU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
There's another part to Wall's job at the firm which doesn't have anything to do with case law. Last week, he stayed on the phone with a man for an hour and a half, listening to him talk about the priest who abused him, and who might still be hurting other people. Wall finds himself talking to victims about all kinds of things. Everything he was not allowed to talk about before, back when he was a priest.
沃尔在律所的工作还有一部分与判例法无关。上周，他在电话里和一个男人聊了一个半小时，听他谈论那个虐待他的牧师，那个可能还在伤害其他人的牧师。沃尔发现自己和受害者谈论各种事情。在他还是牧师时被禁止谈论的一切。
I feel I really do pastoral work when I'm working was victims every day, on every single issue.
我觉得我每天在处理受害者时，在每一个问题上，确实是在做牧灵工作。
Before you were part of a holy order. And now you're working with a bunch of lawyers. And it's hard to know-- it's hard to know these days where priests belong on the ethical ladder, but most people know exactly what a lawyer is. So it's odd to hear you talk about this work being more fulfilling in some ways that what you were doing before.
以前你是圣职人员的一部分。现在你和一群律师一起工作。如今很难知道——很难知道牧师在道德天梯上属于哪里，但大多数人确切地知道律师是什么。所以听到你谈论这份工作在某些方面比你以前做的事情更有成就感，这很奇怪。
Well, we're dealing with people at the lowest ebb of where they're at. They're dealing with the greatest pain they've ever experienced. And one of the greatest things that we find is that they can no longer participate in the sacramental life of the church because of the seven sacraments. The one thing that's really clear is that it takes a priest to administer the sacrament. And every sacrament is either through touching or it's through breath, through words. It's in close proximity to the priest. And that is the symbol of their abuse. So we're dealing with some of the most damaged people within the church. And it's a very fulfilling ministry I find in being pastoral to be with them. Because honestly, we're one of the few symbols of hope that they have.
好吧，我们在处理处于人生最低谷的人们。他们正在处理他们经历过的最大的痛苦。我们发现最伟大的事情之一是，他们因为七圣事而再也无法参与教会的圣事生活。唯一清楚的一点是，需要一位牧师来执行圣事。而每一项圣事要么是通过触摸，要么是通过呼吸，通过言语。它就在牧师的近距离内。而那是他们受虐的象征。所以我们在处理教会内最受伤害的一些人。我觉得能在牧灵上陪伴他们是一种非常有成就感的职事。因为老实说，我们是他们拥有的少数希望象征之一。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL'S ULULU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
Patrick Wall is married now. He and his wife have a two-year-old daughter, who they plan to send to Catholic school. They all go to mass every Sunday.
帕特里克·沃尔现在结婚了。他和妻子有一个两岁的女儿，他们计划送她去天主教学校。他们每周日都去参加弥撒。
Carl Marziali attends mass with his family in Los Angeles. Patrick Wall, however, no longer does. Since we first aired this story in 2003, Patrick has worked on nearly a thousand sexual abuse cases involving priests and co-authored a book called Sex, Priests, and Secret Codes: The Catholic Church's 2,000 Year Paper Trail of Sexual Abuse. He says after all this, he no longer believes that the Catholic Church has the capacity to change. His daughter, now eight years old, is not enrolled in Catholic school.
卡尔·马齐亚利（Carl Marziali）和他的家人在洛杉矶参加弥撒。然而，帕特里克·沃尔不再去了。自从我们2003年首次播出这个故事以来，帕特里克处理了近一千起涉及牧师的性虐待案件，并合著了一本书，书名为《性、牧师和密码：天主教会2000年的性虐待纸质记录》。他说，在这一切之后，他不再相信天主教会具备改革的能力。他的女儿现在8岁，没有在天主教学校就读。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL'S ULULU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - 鹿蹄乐队（Deerhoof）的《Angel's Ululu》]
Coming up, enemies on our turf-- controlling the minds of ants, of rats, of you and me. This is not some whacked out conspiracy theory, my friends. This is science. In a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，我们地盘上的敌人——控制蚂蚁、老鼠、你和我。朋友们，这不是什么疯狂的阴谋论。这是科学。一分钟后来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
This is American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Enemy Camp-- stories of what it means to work behind enemy lines. We've arrived at Act Two of our program.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周在我们的节目中，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目是：敌营——讲述在敌后工作的意义。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。
Act Two: Blood Agent. Nature, it turns out, is full of enemy agents, living behind enemy lines, doing their work. Parasites-- they're literally parasites. Carl Zimmer has written a book about the different strategies that these parasites use to survive. And it makes for weirdly compelling reading. For one thing, who knew how prevalent they were?
第二幕：血液代理人。事实证明，自然界中充满了敌方代理人，生活在敌后，做着它们的工作。寄生虫——它们确实是寄生虫。卡尔·齐默（Carl Zimmer）写了一本关于这些寄生虫用来生存的不同策略的书。这读起来非常吸引人。首先，谁知道它们竟然如此普遍？
Most creatures are living inside an enemy. And they are trying to fight that enemy, trying to survive, trying to outwit--
大多数生物都生活在一个敌人内部。它们试图与那个敌人战斗，试图生存，试图智胜——
Just to give people a sense of the range of things that different parasites do, could you tell the story of the parasite that gets into ants, the lancet fluke?
为了让人们了解不同寄生虫所做事情的范围，你能讲讲进入蚂蚁体内的寄生虫——双盘吸虫（lancet fluke）的故事吗？
Sure. Well, the lancet fluke is kind of a flatworm. It starts out as AN egg on the ground. And a snail comes along and eats the egg. And it kind of irritates the snail's system. So eventually it kind of coughs it up. And so there you have this sort of clump of kind OF nail goo with a parasite in it. And while it's disgusting to us, to an ant there's nothing more delicious than snail goo. So the ant comes along. And he it eats the snail goo and the parasite along with it. So now you have these flukes inside the ant. And once they recognize that they're inside the ant, they start doing some strange things. Sort of as the sun is starting to go down, while the other ants are probably heading back to the nest, it gets this uncontrollable urge to climb upwards. It wants to climb up. And what it generally does is it climbs up a blade of grass.
当然。嗯，双盘吸虫是一种扁形虫。它最初是地面上的一个卵。蜗牛来了，吃了那个卵。它会刺激蜗牛的系统。所以最终蜗牛会把它咳出来。所以你就有了这一团带寄生虫的蜗牛粘液。虽然这对我们来说很恶心，但对蚂蚁来说，没有比蜗牛粘液更美味的东西了。所以蚂蚁来了。它吃了蜗牛粘液，连同寄生虫一起吃掉了。所以现在这些吸虫在蚂蚁体内了。一旦它们意识到自己在蚂蚁体内，就开始做一些奇怪的事情。太阳开始下山时，当其他蚂蚁可能正往巢穴赶的时候，它会产生一种无法抑制的向上攀爬的冲动。它想要爬上去。它通常做的是爬上一片草叶。
And what's the advantage to the parasite for the ant to be up there?
寄生虫让蚂蚁爬到那里有什么优势？
Well, it's not too obvious at first. I mean it's not like the parasite wants to take in a better view. The thing is that there are these grazing mammals-- sheep, cows. And that's one their favorite grazing times, towards the end of the day. So the ant goes up there. The sheep comes along. Chews on the grass. The ant gets eaten. Chewed up. Dies. But the flukes, inside the ant, they can survive the digestive acids in the sheep's stomach. And actually sheep are where they like to live. They're their final host.
嗯，起初并不是太明显。我的意思是，寄生虫并不是想看更好的风景。问题是有这些吃草的哺乳动物——绵羊、奶牛。那是它们最喜欢的吃草时间之一，临近一天结束时。所以蚂蚁爬上去了。绵羊来了，嚼草。蚂蚁被吃了。嚼碎。死亡。但是吸虫，在蚂蚁体内，它们可以在绵羊胃里的消化酸中幸存。事实上，绵羊是它们喜欢居住的地方，是它们的最终宿主。
What's so amazing that is it's not just the control that the parasite is having over the ant. That life cycle that you're describing is so complicated. It's having to go through three different animals over the course of its normal life cycle.
最令人惊奇的是，这不仅仅是寄生虫对蚂蚁的控制。你描述的那个生命周期太复杂了。它在正常的生命周期中必须经过三种不同的动物。
Yeah. There actually are some parasites that go through six or seven different animals to get through their life cycle. It's mind boggling.
是的。实际上有些寄生虫要经过六七种不同的动物才能完成它们的生命周期。这令人难以置信。
It's really hard to talk about without kind of ascribing a kind of intentionality to them. They don't have consciousness. They don't have brains in any way. And its hard for us to even understand what they're doing without kind of like putting that on them.
如果不赋予它们某种意图，就很难谈论它们。它们没有意识。它们在任何方面都没有大脑。即使不赋予它们这种意图，我们也很难理解它们在做什么。
Yeah. Because in a sense they are using us or are using other animals or other hosts in such an intentional way. And they seem to know so much. How does a tapeworm inside a fish know that if it makes it flick and flail a certain way, that it'll be easier for a bird to see it. So they can get inside that bird, where it wants to be. It's amazing. And not only to not have brains-- a lot of them don't even have nerves. So it's just this sinister chemical wisdom they have.
是的。因为从某种意义上说，它们以一种非常有目的性的方式利用我们、利用其他动物或其他宿主。而且它们似乎知道得很多。绦虫在鱼体内怎么知道，如果让它抽动和挣扎成某种方式，鸟类更容易看到它。这样它们就可以进入那只鸟体内，进入它想去的地方。这太神奇了。而且不仅没有大脑——它们中的许多甚至没有神经。所以这只是它们拥有的一种邪恶的化学智慧。
And it seems like all the parasites break down into two different groups. There the kinds that actually get inside a host and then kill it off in their drive to survive. And then there are others which actually just kind of live inside and are happily living inside forever. They want the host to survive. Could you just tell the example of the creature that eats the fish's tongue?
而且似乎所有的寄生虫都分为两组。有些种类进入宿主体内，然后在生存的驱动下杀死了它。而另一些则只是住在里面，永远快乐地生活在里面。它们希望宿主生存。你能讲讲那个吃掉鱼舌头的生物的例子吗？
Yeah. This is a particularly creepy one. The parasite in question is called an isopod, which is a kind of crustacean. It looks like a little pill bug or something. But it lives in the water. And what it does is it swims into the mouth of a snapper, a fish. And when it's in there, it's eats that fish's tongue. It just devours the tongue completely. But just the tongue. It stops there. But now this isopod, this parasite does something very weird. It sort of turns around so it's facing front. And kind of hunkers down exactly where the tongue used to be. So if you look in one of these fish's mouths, you see this tongue that has these little eyes in it. It's amazing.
是的。这是一个特别令人毛骨悚然的例子。相关的寄生虫叫等足类动物（isopod），是一种甲壳动物。它看起来像一只小鼠妇之类的东西。但它生活在水里。它的做法是游进鲷鱼的嘴里。当它在里面时，它吃掉了鱼的舌头。它完全吞噬了舌头。但仅此而已，它就停在那里了。但现在这个等足类动物，这个寄生虫做了一件非常奇怪的事情。它转过身，面向前方。并在原来舌头所在的位置蹲下来。所以如果你往这些鱼的嘴里看，你会看到这个舌头，里面有小眼睛。这太神奇了。
And what scientists think then happens is that the fish can then sort of use the parasite as its tongue. It'll go out and it'll catch some food. And it'll catch a fish. And will crush up the food on the back of this parasite. The fish I guess doesn't mind too if it can still get its meal I guess. And the fish can then kind of get back to its life.
科学家认为接下来发生的事情是，鱼可以利用这个寄生虫作为它的舌头。它会出去捕捉一些食物。它会捕捉一条鱼，并在这个寄生虫的背上压碎食物。我想鱼如果不介意的话，它仍然可以吃到饭。然后鱼可以回到它的生活中。
So many of these stories just are such gross-out stories on a visceral level.
这么多故事在本质上都是让人觉得恶心的故事。
Well, it's funny because it disturbs us when we talk about that when it comes to parasites. But I mean why doesn't it disturb us when we talk about a lion? We name football teams after lions.
嗯，很有趣，因为当我们谈论寄生虫时，这会困扰我们。但我的意思是，当我们谈论狮子时，为什么不会困扰我们？我们以狮子的名字命名足球队。
Yeah.
是的。
But we don't name football teams after tapeworms. You don't have the Tapeworms or something like that. We don't want to think about it. But we admire these predators. But what are these predators doing? These predators are taking advantage of these other life forms. They're just sort of eating them from the outside, I guess you could say. I mean to my mind, it's just a lot more cool when they're on the inside, trying to figure out how to make this work.
但我们不以绦虫的名字命名足球队。你没有“绦虫队”之类的。我们不想考虑它。但我们钦佩这些掠食者。可这些掠食者在做什么？这些掠食者在利用其他生命形式。我想你可以说它们只是从外部吃掉它们。在我看来，当它们在内部，试图弄清楚如何让这种运作方式起作用时，这看起来更酷。
Thinking about this as much as you have, do you start to see everything as being parasites?
思考了这么多，你开始觉得万物皆是寄生虫吗？
I see a lot of things as being parasites. Parasites are the most successful life form on Earth. And it could be as many as three parasites for every one free living species. It's hard to say.
我看到很多东西都是寄生虫。寄生虫是地球上最成功的生命形式。每一种自由生活的物种可能就有多达三种寄生虫。很难说。
Huh.
呵。
And if you're not a species that is living inside another thing, then you're a species with something living inside of you.
如果你不是一种生活在其他事物内部的物种，那么你就是一个有某种东西生活在你内部的物种。
Is one side winning?
哪一方在赢？
I'd say the parasites have the upper hand because they're just doing so very well.
我想说寄生虫占上风，因为它们做得太好了。
The parasites have the upper hand?
寄生虫占上风？
Sure. Yeah. I mean they have the most species. They're getting around all these defenses. I mean there are things they do that either we don't know how they do it or if we know how they do it, we can't reproduce it. We just stand in awe of it.
当然。是的。我的意思是，它们拥有最多的物种。它们正在绕过所有这些防御。我的意思是，它们所做的事情，要么我们不知道它们是怎么做的，要么如果我们知道是怎么做的，我们也无法复制它。我们只是对此充满敬畏。
I know. But we know about them. They don't know about us. Like we're the ones with the brains and the thinking and the consciousness.
我知道。但我们知道它们。它们不知道我们。就像我们拥有大脑、思想和意识。
Well, then maybe you're overselling your brain you know. I mean the brain's a wonderful thing. But these parasites are able to pull the strings in those brains in a lot of cases. Say for example, a rat. Rats are very smart animals. I mean they know how to learn. They know how to figure out their surroundings. But there's a parasite called toxoplasma, that's a single-celled parasite. And they pick it up on the ground. And when it gets into them, they suddenly lose their fear of the smell of cats. Otherwise, they're totally the same. Then the cat eats them. And then toxoplasma gets into its final host, which is the cat. So even though you've got a brain, you're still being pushed towards your doom by this single-celled parasite.
好吧，那你可能高估了你的大脑。我的意思是，大脑是一件美妙的事情。但在很多情况下，这些寄生虫能够拉动这些大脑中的弦。举个例子，老鼠。老鼠是非常聪明的动物。我的意思是它们知道如何学习。它们知道如何弄清楚周围的环境。但有一种叫弓形虫（toxoplasma）的寄生虫，它是单细胞寄生虫。它们在地上拾取它。当它进入它们体内时，它们突然失去了对猫的气味的恐惧。除此之外，它们完全一样。然后猫吃了它们。然后弓形虫进入了它的最终宿主，也就是猫。所以即使你有大脑，你仍然被这种单细胞寄生虫推向你的毁灭。
Mr. Zimmer, whose side are you on?
齐默先生，你站在哪一边？
I think I'm on the parasite's side when it comes to getting a bad rap. I'm their PR man.
我觉得在寄生虫被误解这方面，我站在它们这边。我是它们的公关人员。
Because Mr. Zimmer, at some point we're all going to have to choose sides in this war. Speaking for the other humans, I want to say you're either with us or against us.
因为齐默先生，在某个时候我们都必须在这场战争中选择阵营。代表其他人，我想说你要么和我们站在一起，要么站在我们对立面。
Well, it's funny. I have not gotten seriously sick in my life. Knock on wood. And I have actually gone to places where there are a lot of parasites around, in order to report on how people are dealing with them. And I didn't get sick. I was really scared. But I didn't get sick. I didn't get malaria. I didn't get river blindness. I didn't get sleeping sickness.
嗯，很有趣。我这辈子还没得过严重的疾病。木头敲敲。我实际上去过有很多寄生虫的地方，为了报道人们是如何应对它们的。我没生病。我很害怕。但我没生病。我没得疟疾。我没得河盲症。我没得昏睡病。
What is this? Are you saying this because they could sense that you are in league with them?
这是什么？你说这话是因为它们能感觉到你和它们是一伙的吗？
Who knows? Well, maybe they think I'm here to serve their purpose.
谁知道呢？好吧，也许它们认为我是为了实现它们的目的而来的。
Carl Zimmer. His book, the perfect reading material if you ever whenever long talk with an eight-year-old boy, is Parasite Rex.
卡尔·齐默。他的书，如果你曾经和八岁的小男孩有过长时间的谈话，这是完美的阅读材料，叫《寄生虫雷克斯》（Parasite Rex）。
[MUSIC - "I LIVE OFF YOU" - BY X-RAY SPEX]
[音乐 - X-Ray Spex的《I Live Off You》]
Act Three. As The Worm Turns. Well, as long as we're on the subject of apologists for parasites, let's hear this story from the staff of Radiolab . Here's Radiolab's host Robert Krulwich and reporter Patrick Walters.
第三幕。当虫子蠕动时。好吧，既然我们提到了寄生虫的辩护者，让我们听听来自Radiolab员工的这个故事。这是Radiolab的主持人罗伯特·克鲁维奇（Robert Krulwich）和记者帕特里克·沃尔特斯（Patrick Walters）。
So Patrick, are you there?
帕特里克，你在那里吗？
Yeah, I'm here, Robert.
是的，我在，罗伯特。
So just tell us a little bit about this fellow, what's his name exactly?
那么给我们讲讲这个家伙，他到底叫什么名字？
His name is Jasper Lawrence. He actually grew up in England. He grew up in this little farm in the southwest corner of England. And it's important to know before hearing any part of his story, that Jasper has had allergies for pretty much his whole life.
他叫贾斯珀·劳伦斯（Jasper Lawrence）。他实际上是在英国长大的。他在英国西南角的一个小农场长大。在听到他故事的任何部分之前，了解这一点很重要：贾斯珀几乎一生都有过敏症。
On really bad days, my eyes would swell up so much from pollen or air borne allergens that they would feel like they were swelling shut. I could feel my eyes squeaking in my sockets. It was an enormously uncomfortable feeling.
在非常糟糕的日子里，我的眼睛会因为花粉或空气传播的过敏原肿胀得厉害，感觉它们快要肿得闭上了。我能感觉到我的眼睛在眼窝里吱吱作响。那是一种极其不舒服的感觉。
But it was nothing debilitating.
但这没什么让人虚弱的。
They were just allergies.
那只是过敏。
And so he's just like most other people who have allergies. You just learn to deal with it.
所以他就像大多数有这种过敏症的人一样。你只是学会去应对它。
You know, you live with it. But what changed for me in my late 20s, early 30s was my asthma. And at that time I was living in Santa Cruz. I was relatively recently married. We had three cats that had been grandfathered in with the relationship. And I started a landscaping business. I really didn't work for someone else.
你知道，你忍受着它。但我在20多岁末、30多岁初改变的是我的哮喘。当时我住在圣克鲁斯。我结婚不久。我们有三只猫，那是关系中顺带带来的。我创办了一家景观设计公司。我真的不是为别人工作。
I think someone with allergies, a landscaping business, that seems kind of unexpected.
我想一个有过敏症的人开景观设计公司，这似乎有点出乎意料。
Stupid is actually the word for it. And within six months or a year--
愚蠢才是这个词。在六个月或一年内——
He starts to notice--
他开始注意到——
--this really weird barking cough.
——那种非常奇怪的吠叫般的咳嗽。
Was there anything in particular that brought this on?
有什么特别引起这个的原因吗？
No. It was just sitting and breathing. Cats certainly didn't help.
没有。只是坐着呼吸。猫当然没有帮助。
Right.
对。
And during that period, my asthma got much worse, very, very quickly. By the time it was 1996, 1997, I was seeing specialists, having skin allergen tests, and cycling through emergency inhalers, trying Singulair and all these other drugs that were coming on the market. I was being hospitalized at least couple of times a year. I mean I looked terrible. I had dark eyes and pale, waxy skin. I had that allergic look. It was a really bad time.
在那期间，我的哮喘变得严重得多，非常、非常快。到1996年、1997年时，我看专家，做皮肤过敏原测试，循环使用急救吸入器，尝试欣单利（Singulair）和市面上所有这些其他药物。我每年至少住院几次。我的意思是，我看起来糟透了。我有黑眼圈，皮肤苍白蜡黄。我看起来就是一副过敏的样子。那是一段非常糟糕的时光。
And he decides in the summer of 2004 to take a vacation.
他在2004年夏天决定去度假。
He made this visit to England.
他去了英国。
Yeah. I took my two daughters back to see my aunt who had raised me. Very early in the visit, I was sitting at her kitchen table. And she asked me if I'd seen a BBC documentary about parasites and their connection with things like asthma and allergies and multiple sclerosis. And of course I hadn't. But I went upstairs and got on the internet after lunch. And I stayed on the internet until perhaps 2:00 in the morning. I didn't stop. I was reading and reading the work of all these researchers.
是的，我带着我的两个女儿回去看望抚养我的姑姑。访问的初期，我坐在她的厨房餐桌旁。她问我是否看过一部关于寄生虫及其与哮喘、过敏和多发性硬化症联系的BBC纪录片。当然我没看过。但午饭后我上楼上网，一直待到凌晨两点左右。我没停下来。我一直在阅读所有这些研究人员的作品。
One study after the next.
一项又一项研究。
And Japan. And epidemiological studies in Africa. Animal models of multiple sclerosis.
还有日本。还有非洲的流行病学研究。多发性硬化症的动物模型。
This enormous weight of evidence that in the developing world people don't really have asthma or allergies. And what he discovers is that behind all of this, to his shock, is hookworms.
这种巨大的证据权重表明，在发展中国家，人们并没有真正的哮喘或过敏。令他震惊的是，他发现这一切背后的原因是钩虫。
Hookworm?
钩虫？
Yeah. Hookworms.
是的。钩虫。
Yeah. I learned that asthma was 50% less likely in someone who had a hookworm infection.
是的，我了解到，感染钩虫的人患哮喘的可能性降低了50%。
So this sort of just like hits you.
所以这就像击中你了。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
What did you think when you read that?
当你读到那个时，你在想什么？
Oh, I immediately was determined to obtain hookworm. Immediately. I couldn't wait.
哦，我立刻下定决心要获得钩虫。立刻。我等不及了。
So hookworms are these very tiny worms the size of a little hair. But if you take a microscope in you zoom way in, they have this big circular mouth mouth, brimming full of pointy teeth. very. Scary to look at. They have these toothy mouths so that they can borough up through your feet, ride through your blood, and eventually end up down in your gut, and start chewing on the inside of your intestines.
所以钩虫是这种非常细小的蠕虫，像一根小头发那么大。但如果你用显微镜放大看，它们有一个巨大的圆形口，充满了尖锐的牙齿。看起来非常吓人。它们有这些长满牙齿的嘴，这样它们就可以钻进你的脚，通过血液游走，最终降落在你的肠道里，并开始啃食你肠子的内部。
This guy wants hookworms in his intestines?
这个家伙想要钩虫在他的肠子里？
Absolutely.
绝对。
And so did you just Google it?
所以你只是谷歌搜索了一下？
Yeah. Hookworms for sale. I mean someone has got to be selling them. But nothing. I contacted every laboratory supply company in the world and parasitology research centers. And they all said the same thing. No. Various flavors of no. And so I came to the conclusion that I was going to have to go to the tropics.
是的。钩虫出售。我的意思是肯定有人在卖它们。但什么都没有。我联系了世界上所有的实验室供应公司和寄生虫学研究中心。他们都说了同样的话：不。各种各样的“不”。所以我得出的结论是，我必须去热带地区。
So fast forward a little. Jasper is in Cameroon, along the coast.
稍微快进一下。贾斯珀在喀麦隆，沿着海岸。
Quite literally and figuratively the armpit of Africa.
从字面意义和比喻意义上讲，非洲的腋窝。
He's 200 miles north of the equator. It's extremely hot. He finds a guy to drive them around. And so and his driver would go to a village--
他在赤道以北200英里。天气极热。他找了一个人开车带他们到处转。所以他和他的司机去了一个村庄——
We'd get out of the car.
我们下车。
--walk up to these villagers and ask them if they could see the latrine.
——走到这些村民面前，问他们是否能看看厕所。
Just an open area of ground. Usually with bushes so people could have a little bit privacy. And I would go over to the area, remove my shoes, and start walking. The first time I did that I almost couldn't do it. It must have been 110 degrees that day-- 100% humidity. And the stench and the noise from the insects. It was so repulsive and so disgusting.
只是地上一片开放区域。通常有灌木丛，所以人们可以有一点点隐私。我会走到那个区域，脱掉鞋子，开始走动。我第一次这样做时几乎做不到。那天一定是110度（华氏）——100%的湿度。还有昆虫的恶臭和噪音。这太令人反感和恶心了。
How many villages and latrines do you think you visited?
你觉得你访问了多少个村庄和厕所？
Between 30 and 40.
在30到40个之间。
Jasper spent two weeks there walking around in village latrines and then he flew home.
贾斯珀在那里花了两个星期在乡村厕所里走动，然后他飞回家了。
I got back from Africa in early February. So I was looking at allergy season coming up. And the day I realized that I longer had allergies, that was such a good day. I got into my car and I started driving. And I had the window down. And I felt the breeze blowing across my face. In the past what that meant was that very quickly my eyes would be itching uncontrollably. Snot and phlegm was going to be pouring out of every orifice in my face. And it didn't happen. It didn't happen. I just started screaming in the car. I was so, so happy. And I haven't had an asthma attack since I went to Africa. I no longer have allergies. The vast majority of the benefit that I've experienced has come from hookworm.
我二月初从非洲回来。所以我看到过敏季节就要到了。那天我意识到我不再过敏了，那是美好的一天。我上了车开始开车。我把窗户摇下来。我感觉到微风吹过我的脸。过去这意味着很快我的眼睛会不由自主地发痒。鼻涕和痰会从我脸上的每一个孔里涌出来。但这没发生。它没发生。我开始在车里尖叫。我太、太高兴了。从我去非洲之后，我再没犯过哮喘。我不再过敏了。我所经历的绝大多数好处都来自钩虫。
What is the hookworm doing? Do you know?
钩虫在做什么？你知道吗？
Well, so the immune system that we learn about in elementary school is all about like these attack cells that go after foreign invaders and destroy them.
嗯，我们在小学学到的免疫系统全是关于这些攻击外国入侵者并摧毁它们的攻击细胞。
Right.
对。
And that's a big important part of the immune system. But if the immune system were allowed to attack and destroy things unchecked, it could kill you. And there are lots of diseases where the primary symptoms are caused by the immune system attacking the body that's it's really designed to protect. Allergies and asthma are just two of these. Some of the more serious ones are like Type 1 diabetes, multiple sclerosis, Crohn's disease, in which the immune system actually starts attacking the inside of the intestines.
那是免疫系统重要的一部分。但如果免疫系统被允许不受限制地攻击和摧毁东西，它可能会杀死你。有许多疾病的主要症状是由免疫系统攻击它本应保护的身体造成的。过敏和哮喘只是其中两个。一些更严重的疾病，比如1型糖尿病、多发性硬化症、克罗恩病，在这些疾病中，免疫系统实际上开始攻击肠道内部。
Uhhuh.
嗯哼。
There are like 80 of these diseases.
大约有80种这类疾病。
Eighty of them.
80种。
And so what scientists have found in lots and lots of mouse studies and in some human studies to this point too, is that once the hookworms get inside the gut and the immune system actually starts attacking, somehow hookworms actually stimulate these cells, which just quiet things down. And tell the attack cells to stop attacking.
所以科学家在大量的鼠标研究和目前一些人类研究中发现，一旦钩虫进入肠道，免疫系统开始攻击，不知何故，钩虫实际上刺激了这些细胞，从而使事情安静下来。并告诉攻击细胞停止攻击。
So these are like lullaby cells?
所以这些就像催眠细胞？
Exactly. What lots and lots of scientists think-- Joel Weinstock--
正是如此。许多许多科学家认为——乔尔·温斯托克（Joel Weinstock）——
Joel Weinstock. Tufts Medical Center.
乔尔·温斯托克。塔夫茨医疗中心。
And dozens of others is that over--
还有其他几十个人，那就是经过——
--thousands and thousands of years--
——数千数万年——
Hookworms almost developed in tandem with the human immune system.
钩虫几乎与人类免疫系统协同发展。
Co-evolution. Parasites living within your body, your immune system changes.
共同进化。寄生虫生活在你的体内，你的免疫系统发生了变化。
If you got to a point where the hookworms could survive safely--
如果你达到了一个点，钩虫可以安全生存——
The worm gets a home. There's food coming down the food pipe and in return--
蠕虫得到了一个家。食物顺着食管下来，作为回报——
The human immune system gains some kind of--
人类免疫系统获得某种——
Some form of--
某种形式的——
Positive regulatory
积极的调节
--advantage.
——优势。
So that if you had this glitch where your immune system started attacking your own body, the presence of the hookworms would keep things--
所以，如果你有这种免疫系统开始攻击你自己身体的小故障，钩虫的存在会使事情——
--controlled. That's the gift. You do something for the worm. The worm does something for you.
——受到控制。这就是礼物。你为蠕虫做点什么，蠕虫也为你做点什么。
So then by that logic, what we in the West, in the richer countries have done stupidly is we have cleaned ourselves up too much. And we don't have enough wormies in us.
所以根据那个逻辑，我们在西方，在更富裕的国家所做的愚蠢的事情就是我们把自己清理得太干净了。我们体内没有足够的虫子。
Yeah, this is called--
是的，这被称为——
They call it the hygiene hypothesis.
他们称之为“卫生假说”。
--the hygiene hypothesis. That we're not dirty enough.
——卫生假说。我们不够脏。
Too clean.
太干净了。
We function like rain forests. We're ecosystems. And we've entirely eliminated a class of organism that co-evolved with us and our genetic predecessors for millions of years.
我们的功能就像雨林。我们是生态系统。我们完全消除了一个与我们及我们的遗传先辈共同进化了数百万年的生物类别。
Now, I don't want to leave the impression that hygiene is bad for you. People can't go back to living in filth-- kids playing in sewage by the river bank. But in improving our hygiene, we're also excluding organisms that may be important for making us well.
现在，我不想留下卫生对你有害的印象。人们不能回到生活在污秽中——孩子们在河岸边的污水里玩耍。但在改善卫生的同时，我们也排除了可能对让我们健康很重要的生物。
So then what does Jasper do about all of this?
那么贾斯珀对此做了什么？
He decides to start a business selling hookworm to people.
他决定开始做生意，向人们出售钩虫。
What?
什么？
You can call him up. And he will literally Fed-Ex a dose of hookworms to your door.
你可以给他打电话。他会真的通过联邦快递（Fed-Ex）把一剂钩虫送到你门口。
How?
怎么做？
Sorry, to break in for a second--
抱歉，打断一下——
Pat--
帕特——
Where does he get the hookworm from?
他从哪里得到钩虫的？
This is weird. Jasper gets the hookworm from himself.
这很奇怪。贾斯珀从他自己身上得到钩虫。
Could you describe how you go about getting hookworm from your stool into one of your patients?
你能描述一下你是如何把钩虫从你的粪便中弄出来，放进你的病人身上吗？
Well, it's a very easy organism to work with. It gets up and it walks out of it. So it doesn't take an enormous amount of work to separate it from the feces. And then having done that, I repeatedly wash them in solutions of antibiotics to make sure that anything that could live on them is killed. People contact us. We'll have them complete a questionnaire, submit a recent blood test. Then we'll ship them a dose and all the materials and equipment and the instructions necessary to infect themselves.
嗯，这是一种很容易操作的生物。它站起来，自己走出来。所以不需要花巨大的力气把它从粪便中分离出来。然后做到这一点后，我反复在抗生素溶液中清洗它们，以确保任何可能生活在它们身上的东西都被杀死了。人们联系我们。我们会让他们完成一份问卷，提交一份最近的血液检查。然后我们会寄给他们一剂药和感染自己所需的所有材料、设备和说明。
Is this a safe thing to do?
这样做安全吗？
Jasper has done tons and tons of research. But he's not a doctor.
贾斯珀做了成吨成吨的研究。但他不是医生。
Right.
对。
The treatment is not approved by the FDA.
这种治疗没有得到FDA（美国食品药品监督管理局）批准。
That's what I wonder. Is there any serious sort of double-blind study trying to figure out whether some safe delivery of hookworm might make sense?
我就是想知道这个。有没有任何严重的双盲研究试图找出某种安全的钩虫输送方式是否说得通？
Yes. So one of one of the guys who was sort of a pioneer in this hookworm research is David Pritchard.
有的。所以其中一个在钩虫研究方面算是先驱的人是大卫·普里查德（David Pritchard）。
I'm Professor David Pritchard.
我是大卫·普里查德教授。
Immunologist and parasitologist.
免疫学家和寄生虫学家。
--at the University of Nottingham where I study parasites and the wound healing properties of maggots. So we've now got two safety trials under our belts. But we've yet to conduct the trials to show that therapeutic benefit results from infection with worms.
——在诺丁汉大学，我研究寄生虫和蛆虫的伤口愈合特性。所以我们现在已经进行了两项安全性试验。但我们尚未进行试验来证明感染蠕虫能产生治疗益处。
So Pritchard infected himself pretty much just to make sure that it was safe.
所以普里查德几乎只是为了确保它是安全的而感染了自己。
What we did was, 10 of us in the lab took worms at different doses. We were either given 10, 25, 50, or 100 worms. And then we had to report on the symptoms. And on the back of that study, we determined that 10 worms were tolerated.
我们做的是，实验室里的10个人服用了不同剂量的蠕虫。我们被给予了10、25、50或100条蠕虫。然后我们必须报告症状。在那项研究的基础上，我们确定10条蠕虫是可以耐受的。
But Pritchard, when he did this proof of safety study, he actually give himself 50 hookworms.
但普里查德，当他做这个安全性研究时，他实际上给了自己50条钩虫。
Oh.
哦。
Which put him out of commission for awhile.
这让他有一段时间没法工作了。
Well, I felt pretty bad. I mean pain in the gut really. You could feel them. Because they are biting on your tissues.
嗯，我感觉很糟。我的意思是肠子里真的很痛。你能感觉到它们。因为它们在啃食你的组织。
I mean if you have too many hookworms, they can cause things like diarrhea. And the most serious side effect and the side effect that makes them sort of a public health enemy is that they can give you anemia.
我的意思是，如果你有太多的钩虫，它们会导致腹泻之类的症状。而最严重的副作用，也是让它们成为公众健康敌人的副作用，是它们会导致贫血。
So if you have too many, you lose quite a bit of blood to these parasites.
所以如果你有太多，你会因为这些寄生虫损失相当多的血。
Well, if you take too many hookworm, which you're not going to, if you come to us, the worse thing you're going to get is anemia. But it's not like you wake up one morning in your drained of blood. It's very slow to develop. And it's very easy to deal with.
嗯，如果你服用太多的钩虫，你是不会那样的，如果你来找我们的话，你能得到的最坏的事情就是贫血。但并不是说你某天早上醒来血液被抽干了。它发展得很慢。而且很容易处理。
Jasper's kind of just gone for it. You know, it's a very sort of like cowboy move.
贾斯珀就像直接就这样做了。你知道，这是一个非常牛仔式的举动。
So the scientific community, I think they believe that I'm premature--
所以我认为科学界相信我太超前了——
It's not FDA approved.
它没有经过FDA批准。
--in offering this to the public.
——向公众提供这个。
You don't know what it is. You don't know it's purity. It's not safe.
你不知道它是什么。你不知道它的纯度。它不安全。
But I've talked to several clients who have really severe allergies and asthma. They say they're just achieved these great results. And Jasper also says he's seen success with a few multiple sclerosis patients and several Crohn's disease patients too.
但我谈过几个有严重过敏和哮喘的客户。他们说他们只是取得了这些巨大的成果。贾斯珀也说他已经看到一些多发性硬化症患者和几个克罗恩病患者的成功。
Like how many people do you think that you have infected?
比如你觉得你已经感染了多少人？
It's about 85 right now.
现在大约85个。
How is business? Is it everything that--
生意怎么样？它是一切——
Business is adequate. But I honestly don't know why I don't wake up in the morning with my front garden 20 deep with people with ulcerative collitis, Crohn's disease, allergies. I just don't know why I'm not completely buried.
生意还可以。但我真的不知道为什么我早上醒来时没有发现我前院里挤满了患有溃疡性结肠炎、克罗恩病、过敏症的人。我只是不知道为什么我没有被完全淹没。
The way he sees it, people are scared.
在他看来，人们害怕。
Well, they're the people who are coming from the point of view of what they learned in kindergarten about clean drinking water and sewers. To them, worms and parasites are so repulsive that there is nothing good to be said about them. But I can make you better. It's simple. It's cheap. I mean for god's sakes, these organisms fall out my rear end every day, a half a million at a time. The raw material is human excrement for god's sake. All people have to do is open their minds. Are you really that scared of a little worm?
好吧，他们是那些从幼儿园学到的关于洁净饮用水和下水道观点出发的人。对他们来说，蠕虫和寄生虫是如此令人反感，以至于关于它们没什么好话可说。但我可以让你好起来。这很简单。这很便宜。我的意思是，看在上帝的份上，这些生物每天从我屁股里掉出来，一次五十万条。我的意思是，原料是人类排泄物。人们所要做的只是敞开心扉。你真的那么害怕一条小虫子吗？
Thanks to Patrick Walters and the hosts of Radiolab , Jad Abumrad and Robert Krulwich for that story. After that story was first broadcast, the Food and Drug Administration decided to pay a visit to Jasper Lawrence's house in Santa Cruz. Officials inspected the lab where he harvests his hookworms, told him he had to shut down his operation. That night, Jasper and his wife packed up their belongings and fled the country, so he could keep harvesting and selling hookworms. Jasper's website is autoimmunetherapies.com. And before you get any big ideas about ordering some hookworms, he is not shipping worms right now to the United States of America.
感谢帕特里克·沃尔特斯以及Radiolab的主持人贾德·阿布姆拉德（Jad Abumrad）和罗伯特·克鲁维奇带来那个故事。那个故事首次播出后，食品药品监督管理局决定造访贾斯珀·劳伦斯在圣克鲁斯的家。官员们检查了他收获钩虫的实验室，告诉他必须关闭他的行动。那天晚上，贾斯珀和他的妻子收拾好行李逃离了该国，这样他就可以继续收获和销售钩虫。贾斯珀的网站是autoimmunetherapies.com。在你有任何关于订购一些钩虫的大想法之前，他现在没有向美利坚合众国运送蠕虫。
Act Four. Sleeping With Your Enemy. We have this story about what is hidden inside of us-- the secret agents within. From writer Etgar Keret. Among other things, he says that this is a story of his real-life wife. Actor Matt Malloy reads it for it. A quick warning for listeners before we begin. This story acknowledges the existence of sex.
第四幕。与你的敌人同眠。我们有这个关于我们体内隐藏着什么的故事——内在的秘密代理人。来自作家埃特加·凯雷特（Etgar Keret）。除此之外，他说这是关于他现实生活中妻子的故事。演员马特·马洛伊（Matt Malloy）为它朗读。在开始之前，给听众一个小警告。这个故事承认性的存在。
Surprised: Of course I was surprised. You go out with a girl, first date, second date, a restaurant here, a movie there. Always just matinees. You start sleeping together. The sex is dynamite. And pretty soon there's feeling too. And then one day, she arrives all weepy. And you hug her. And tell her to take it easy. That everything's OK. She says she can't stand it anymore. She has this secret. Not just a secret. Something really awful. A curse. Something she's been wanting to tell you the whole time, but she didn't have the guts. This thing, it's been weighing down on her like a ton of bricks. And now she's gotta tell you. She's simply got to.
惊讶：当然我很惊讶。你和一个女孩出去，第一次约会，第二次约会，在这里的一家餐厅，在那里的电影院。总是看日场电影。你们开始发生性关系。性爱是爆炸性的。很快也有了感情。然后有一天，她带着泪水来了。你拥抱她，告诉她放轻松，一切都会好起来的。她说她再也忍受不了了。她有一个秘密。不仅仅是一个秘密。真的很糟糕的东西。一个诅咒。她一直想告诉你却一直没有勇气的某种东西。这个东西，一直像一吨重的砖块一样压在她身上。现在她必须告诉你。她实在必须告诉你。
But she knows that as soon as she does, you'll leave her. And you'd be absolutely right, too. And right after that, she starts crying all over again. "I won't leave you," you tell her. "I won't. I love you." You may look a little upset, but you're not. And even if you are, it's about her crying, not about her secret. You know by now that these secrets that always make a woman fall to pieces are usually nothing. And you hug them and say, "It's all right. It's OK." Or shh, if they don't stop. "It's something really terrible," she insists, as if she's picked up on how nonchalant you are about it, even though you tried to hide it. "In the pit of your stomach it may sound terrible," you tell her. "But that's mostly because of the acoustics. Soon as you let it out, it won't seem nearly as bad," you'll see. And she almost believes it. She hesitates a minute and then asks, "What if I told you that at night I turn into a heavy, hairy man with no neck, with a gold ring on his pinky? Would you still love me?"
但她知道一旦她说了，你就会离开她。而且你也会绝对正确的。在那之后，她又开始哭了起来。“我不会离开你，”你告诉她。“我不会。我爱你。”你可能看起来有点难过，但你没有。即使你难过了，那也是因为她哭了，而不是因为她的秘密。你现在知道了，这些总是让女人崩溃的秘密通常没什么大不了的。你拥抱她们说：“没关系。一切都好。”如果她们不停下来就嘘嘘她们。“这真的是一件可怕的事，”她坚持说，好像她察觉到你对此有多么漫不经心，即使你试着隐藏它。“在你的心底，这听起来可能很可怕，”你告诉她。“但这主要是因为声学效果。一旦你说出来，它看起来就不会那么糟了，”你会看到的。她几乎相信了。她犹豫了一分钟，然后问：“如果我告诉你，在晚上我变成一个又重、又毛茸茸、没脖子、小指上戴着金戒指的男人呢？你还会爱我吗？”
And you tell her, "Of course, you would." What else can you say, that you wouldn't? She's simply trying to test you to see whether you love her unconditionally. And you've always been a winner at tests. The truth is, as soon as you say it, she melts. And you screw, right there in the living room. And afterwards, you lie there holding other tight. And she cries because she's so relieved. And you cry too. Go figure. And unlike all the other times, she doesn't get up and leave. She stays there and falls asleep. You lie awake, looking at her beautiful body, at the sunset outside, at moon appearing as if out of nowhere, at the silvery light flickering over her body, stroking the hair on her back.
你告诉她：“当然，我会。”你还能说什么，说你不爱吗？她只是在试图测试你，看你是否无条件地爱她。而且你一直是一个测试赢家。事实是，一旦你说出来，她就融化了。你们就在客厅里做爱。事后，你躺在那里紧紧抱着她。她哭是因为她如释重负。你也哭了。去想吧。而且不像其他所有时候，她没有起来离开。她留在那里睡着了。你躺着清醒，看着她美丽的身体，看着外面的日落，看着月亮不知从哪里出现，看着银色的光在她身体上闪烁，抚摸她背上的毛发。
And within less than five minutes, you find yourself lying next to this guy. This short, fat guy. And the guy gets up and smiles at you and gets dressed awkwardly. He leaves the room and you follow him, spellbound. He's in the den now. His thick fingers fiddling with the remote, zapping to the sports channels-- championship football. When they miss a pass, he curses the TV. When they score, he gets up and does this little victory dance. After the game, he tells you his throat is dry and his stomach is growling. He could really use a beer and a nice hunk of meat, well done if possible, with lots of onion rings. But he'd settle for some pork chops too. So you get into the car and take him to this restaurant that he knows about and you don't. This new twist has you worried. It really does. But you have no idea what to do about it. Your command and control centers are down. You shift gears at the exit, in a daze. And he's right there beside you in the passenger seat, tapping that gold-ringed pinky of his. At the next intersection, he rolls down his window, winks at you, and yells at this chick who's thumbing a ride. "Hey, baby. Wanna play nanny goat and ride in the back?
不到五分钟，你发现自己躺在这个家伙旁边。这个又矮又胖的家伙。那个家伙起床对你笑了笑，笨拙地穿上衣服。他离开房间，你着了魔一样跟着他。他在书房里。他粗壮的手指摆弄着遥控器，按到体育频道——冠军橄榄球赛。当他们错过一次传球时，他咒骂电视。当他们得分时，他站起来跳起这个小小的胜利之舞。比赛结束后，他告诉你他嗓子干，肚子在咕咕叫。他真的可以喝点啤酒和一块不错的肉，如果可能的话做得熟一点，配上很多洋葱圈。但他对猪排也心满意足。所以你上车带他去一家他知道而你不知道的餐厅。这种新的转折让你担心。真的担心。但你不知道对此该怎么办。你的指挥和控制中心瘫痪了。你在出口处换档，神志恍惚。而他就坐在你旁边的副驾驶座上，敲着他那个戴金戒指的小指。在下一个十字路口，他摇下车窗，对你眨眨眼，对那个正在搭便车的妞大喊：“嘿，宝贝。想玩保姆羊，坐在后面吗？”
Later, the two of you pack in the steak and the chops and the onion rings, until you're about to explode. And he enjoys every bite. And laughs like a baby. And all that time you keep telling yourself, it's gotta be a dream. A bizarre dream, yes. But definitely one that you'll snap out of any minute. On the way back, you ask him where to let him off? And he pretends not to hear you. But he looks despondent. So you wind up taking him back home with you. It's almost 3:00 a.m. "I'm going to hit the sack," you tell him. And he waves to you. And stays in the bean bag chair, staring at the Fashion channel. You wake up the next morning exhausted, with a slight stomach ache. And there she is, in the living room still dozing. By the time you've had your shower, she's up. She hugs you guiltily. And you're too embarrassed to say anything.
后来，你们两个塞进牛排、猪排和洋葱圈，直到你们快要爆炸。他享受每一口。笑得像个婴儿。而在那段时间里，你一直告诉自己，这一定是场梦。一场离奇的梦，是的。但绝对是你随时会醒来的那种。在回来的路上，你问他在哪里让他下车？他假装没听见。但他看起来很沮丧。所以你最终把他带回了家。快凌晨3点了。“我要去睡觉了，”你告诉他。他向你挥手。留在懒人沙发里，盯着时尚频道。第二天早上你精疲力尽地醒来，肚子微微作痛。而她就在客厅里还在打盹。等你洗完澡，她已经起来了。她内疚地拥抱你。你太尴尬了，什么也没说。
Time goes by and you're still together. The sex just gets better and better. And she's not so young anymore. And neither are you. And suddenly you find yourselves talking about a baby. And at night, you and the fatsoguy hit the town like you've never done in your life. He takes you to restaurants and bars you didn't even know existed. And you dance on tables together, beak plates likes there's no tomorrow. He's really nice, the fatso guy. A little crass, especially with women. Sometimes coming out with things that make you just want to die. But other than that, he's great fun to be with. When you first met him, you didn't give a damn about football. But now, you know every team. And whenever one of your favorites wins, you feel like you've made a wish and its come true, which is a pretty exceptional feeling for someone like you, who hardly knows what he wants most of the time. And so it goes. Every night you fall asleep, with him struggling to stay awake for the early scores on ESPN. And in the morning, there she is, the beautiful, forgiving woman that you love too, until it hurts.
时光流逝，你们还在一起。性生活变得越来越好。她也不那么年轻了。你也不年轻了。突然，你们发现自己在谈论孩子。晚上，你和那个胖子像你这辈子从未有过的那样在城里游荡。他带你去一些你甚至不知道存在的餐馆和酒吧。你们一起在桌子上跳舞，像没有明天一样打碎盘子。那个胖子真的很不错。有点粗鲁，特别是在女性面前。有时冒出一些让你只想死的话。但除此以外，和他在一起很有趣。当你第一次见到他时，你对橄榄球一点也不在乎。但现在，你知道每一支球队。每当你喜欢的球队赢了，你就感觉像是许了个愿，梦想成真了，对于像你这样大多数时候几乎不知道自己想要什么的人来说，这是一种相当特殊的感受。就这样。每天晚上你睡着，他努力熬夜看ESPN上的早期得分。早上，她就在那里，你爱的那个美丽、宽容的女人，爱你直到心痛。
Matt Malloy. Reading Etgar Keret's story, "Fatso", which appears in his book, The Nimrod Flipout. Kaaret's most recent collection is The Girl on the Fridge. This story was translated into English by Miriam Shlesinger.
马特·马洛伊。朗读埃特加·凯雷特的故事《胖子》（Fatso），收录在他的书《Nimrod Flipout》中。凯雷特的最新短篇集是《冰箱上的女孩》（The Girl on the Fridge）。这个故事由米里亚姆·施莱辛格（Miriam Shlesinger）翻译成英语。
[MUSIC - "SHE'S GOT EVERYTHING" BY THE KINKS]
[音乐 - The Kinks的《She's Got Everything》]
Radiolab is produced by WNYC and distributed by NPR. Thanks to them. If you're not listening to Radiolab , you should be. The new season starts this week-- radiolab.org. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. The store at our website is back up in operation. And there's an update to our iPhone app. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International, WBEZ. Management oversight for our program by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia, who has just one question for you: Hey, baby. Want to play nanny goat and ride in the back? I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
Radiolab由WNYC制作并由NPR发行。感谢他们。如果你没在听Radiolab，你应该听。新一季本周开始——radiolab.org。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。我们网站上的商店重新开始运作了。我们的iPhone应用程序有一个更新。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台和WBEZ发行。我们的节目由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责管理监督，他只有一个问题要问你：嘿，宝贝。想玩保姆羊，坐在后面吗？我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "SHE'S GOT EVERYTHING" BY THE KINKS]
[音乐 - The Kinks的《She's Got Everything》]